Welcome to the latest series from AJ+.
"San Francisco's Chinatown is the oldest Chinatown in America."
"There's not too many places left in the world like this."
We're all about telling the stories of the underrepresented and misunderstood communities
that make up our country.
"What does it mean to be both Iranian and American?"
"When telling the story of Syrians in America, I'm in a way telling my own story."
By speaking with people on the ground.
"When people think of Chicago, they think 'Oh my God, it's a violent place with crazy people.'
And that's not the truth."
"We don't look like American
people?"
Join us as we visit a new community each month to learn more about their place in U.S. history,
what they're facing today, and how they're preserving their culture for future generations.
Follow us for more Untold America.